there's a lot of pressure on South
Yorkshire police and crime Commissioner
to step down today Sean Wright was
responsible for Children's Services at
Rotherham Council between 2005 and 2010
and we can speak to Sean right now he
joins us now live from Barnsley thanks
very much indeed for talking to us here
this morning what's your reaction to
Alexis Jays report it welcome well I'm
completely astonished by the scale of
the issue that's been identified over
that 17-year period and I'm just as
disgusted as any other right minded
thinking person in rather man indeed
across the country to the scale of this
problem and you know I sought to do
everything possible in my power during
any role that I've held wealth as a
cabinet member and now a South ultra PCC
to make that difference and to protect
and safeguard more children from the
perpetrators that would commit this
heinous crime well let's talk about your
role at least 1,400 children in
Rotherham sexually exploited by criminal
gangs between the years of 1997 and 2013
you've been police and crime
Commissioner since 2012 you were also
responsible for Children's Services on
rodriram Council between 2005 and 2010
this was on your watch wasn't it
well of course when you're a member of
the council with a responsibility for a
particular portfolio you take collective
responsibility and of course at every
stage and even in identified in the
Alexis Jay report every at every stage
that anyone anything was brought to my
attention then I took the appropriate
course of action are supported offices
I made the relevant amount of investment
and I made the case for more resources
be important to safeguarding children
but of course this is not just about
resources it clearly what's been
identified in the report was a range of
other issues from cultural issues to
ethnicity issues and of course that come
as a huge surprise to me because clearly
none of that was brought to my attention
another it been then more robust action
would have been taken of course with the
benefit of hindsight looking back over a
period like this report as a 17 years
speaking to all the main people involved
in safeguarding children during that
that period of time the pictures now
being painted that there was real
significant issues around at the time
that perhaps many people weren't quite
aware of absolutely as a councillor
you're aware of child abuse and the
various forms that that takes including
CSC but what mrs. saw professor J's
painted a picture of is is really an
industrial scale of child abuse that was
taking place and to that extent I was
simply not aware of the scale of that
problem
I'd have been and I'd have been aware of
the issue then LARC am today then
clearly much more action would and could
have been taken well yes and yet
Alexis J also says that after 2004 and
2005 the time that you were in child
charge of Children's Services she says
no one on the council could say that
they didn't know about what was going on
so what did you know well I became well
of course I became the cabinet member in
May 2005 and what the report
demonstrates because mrs. J looked at
every report and every minute of every
meeting that I ever participated in and
actually commented that I was very
supportive every stage that the relevant
investment was made for example in 2006
there's a report about risky business
part of the cows are responsible for
safeguarding children against this and I
doubled the investment and at every
stage of any report being brought
forward then appropriate action was
taken but of course what this report
demonstrates is that lots of information
wasn't escalated up to political level
or indeed to senior management level and
for that I'm usually shocked and usually
sorry that stays like any right minded
thinking human being then more action
would have been taken three reports 2002
2003 and one in 2006 when you were in
charge of Children's Services
we're told they contain stark evidence
and it was very clear what the problem
was that report surely you would have
seen well I can tell you categorically
now that I didn't see any of those
reports in 2002 or 3 I didn't see any of
those reports and the report that came
in 2006 didn't actually come to me it
went to the children's safeguarding
board and it wasn't referred on as far
as I'm aware so none of those reports
refer to any decisions that I made or
could have been met or could have made
with the knowledge or the benefits of
that knowledge at the time so that's a
major Fault in the system you're saying
that you didn't get to see any of these
reports highlighting these claims well
sure I mean what what the report what
the report yeah I'm sorry but what the
report clearly demonstrates is a
timeline from 1997 to the current date
and it shows that hundreds of young
people were let down by various agencies
Raavan Council South Yorkshire Police
being the two main ones and of course I
was involved with rather than children's
services for a period of five years
during the middle of that and what what
I'm saying here is what the report
identifies and what the chief executive
of the council as identified is that
there was systemic failure so any sense
everyone shares responsibility for that
failure and I took my responsibilities
seriously back in 2009 when Ofsted
identified rather and councils Children
Services has not been fit for purpose I
made first of all sure that there was an
action plan in place to make sure that
that was addressed and addressed as
quickly as possible and then in 2010 I
stood down from that position and
subsequently left the council in 2012
and took up the position of South
police commissioner and of course what
you do throughout your career you learn
you gain experience and I brought all
that experience to bear in the current
role that I'm in and over the last two
years I'm very proud of the progress
that South Yorkshire Police has made in
dealing with this very eNOS crime and of
course there's a lot more progress still
to be made because there will always
unfortunately be people around evil
perpetrators of this crime that want to
abuse and take advantage and exploit
young people and I've taken all of that
learning brought it to birth is now a
tenfold increase in the number of
officers dealing with this we've got
over 200 live investigations there's
been a 5 million pounds increase ok I'm
going to interrupt your apologies
because you say everyone takes
responsibility but no one has faced
disciplinary action in the council have
they has anyone face disciplinary action
well that's the matter for the chief
executive to take appropriate action of
any officers or anything acted
inappropriately mr. Kimber is on record
as saying that it will right problem
with a delay I just want to ask you
about the police though because you are
obviously with Lisa and crime
Commissioner has anyone faced given that
the sure not yes but I've spoken to the
Chief Constable yesterday and I've asked
him to take a very careful and close
look at all the recommendations and all
the facts contained within this 138 page
report and where he feels it's necessary
to take action against any individuals
then that action will be taken and
indeed I will be looking forward to
report coming from the chief constable
to identify any lessons that can be
learned any actions that need to be
taken and of course any reference
referrals that need to be made to the
IPCC or indeed any other professional
body will be made believe you me this is
a top priority for South Yorkshire
Police it has been seized 2012 it will
continue to be a top priority going
forward for as long as I'm in this
particular role and I would merely
reiterate what I've said previously that
I apologize to any of the victims
because in the end what's important is
protecting young people and I've always
thought protecting young people I'm a
parent myself and I find it completely
so
destroying to understand that there's so
many young people that have been abused
in this way and there's a responsible
parent responsible adults I'm doing
everything in my power to make sure that
this is adequately tackled here in South
Yorkshire and especially in Rotherham
we're just gonna hear if you can just
wait just a moment we're just gonna hear
from the report author Alexis J
something that she had to say yesterday
if all of the authorities involved
officers and members had been less
concerned with their own agendas and
prejudices and kept their focus on the
children's welfare some of these
children might not have suffered that
the abuse and brutality we read about
and heard about what's your response to
that well of course if professor J is
found areas of concern around actually
should have named the people involved I
gave an interview to Miss J as part of
this this review and I was very explicit
that where criticism should be made or
needed to be made it should be as open
and explicit as possible and you know if
that's the findings of Miss J then
that's from Miss J to speak to that but
clearly I wasn't aware or involved in
any inappropriate behavior in that sense
so in a sense the report perhaps could
have gone a little further in
identifying those particularly
responsible because generalizing and
making general statements is obviously
very difficult for the people in
positions to take action to actually
take that appropriate action and you
gave evidence didn't you to the Home
Affairs Select Committee on this issue
in that you said whilst I was aware that
some of the vulnerable young people I
saw could have suffered sexual abuse I
was not informed of individual
circumstances I did not believe it would
have been appropriate for me to request
to meet victims of child sexual
exploitation as this would have been an
invasion of the privacy of these
vulnerable young victims do you regret
that now do you think that you should
have spoken to some of these victims and
found out for yourself what they were
going through
I think there was an entirely
appropriate course of action to take
clearly as an elected politician it's
not appropriate to be asking to speak to
young people that have been victims of
this sort of abuse now clearly I've met
many victims both children and adults
who have made an approach and shared
their story and I've obviously learnt
and understood the the damage that this
does far better as a result of those
conversations but it wouldn't have been
appropriate and it never would should be
appropriate for politicians to directly
ask a young person to explain their
experience that's for professional
professionally trained people that can
give the proper support to these young
people at the appropriate time so I
stand by that statement and I'm very
happy to reiterate it just to be clear
16 years of appalling abuse in many
cases five years on your watch do you
think you should still be in a job that
has responsibility for protecting
children well what the report clearly
identifies is systemic failure it's got
the benefit of eyesight except the
benefit of speaking to a range of people
from chief executives to councillors to
police commanders to people at senior
people within the elf's sector and other
sectors and with all of that knowledge
clearly it paints a picture that there
was systemic failure and of course I was
part of that organisation at the time
and I took that responsibility very
seriously in 2009 when Ofsted prior to
that Ofsted was saying rather than
councils Children Services was rated as
God in 2009 that came in and found areas
that needed improvement and rated the
services inadequate but in 2000 yes so I
stood down in 2010 from that particular
role and took my responsibilities shared
my role in terms of that responsibility
at that time on the council there's then
been a period of time between that and
then I subsequently became the South
Shore police commissioner
with the benefit of Einstein and all the
lessons that have been learned with the
AMA fair select committee reports the
Children's Commissioners reports the
NSPCC and benardos there's been a huge
amount of learning and of course I've
taken all of this and made sure that
it's fully implemented in South
Yorkshire place and it's now making a
difference to many many young more young
people in South Yorkshire and in
Rotherham so I took my responsibilities
seriously I stood down in 2010 and I've
subsequently taken those lessons and
brought them to bear and South Yorkshire
Police even now what's your message for
the victims then today my message is
from my perspective clearly I'm very
sorry for any abuse that took place if I
could have prevented it I would any
right minded human being would want to
protect vulnerable children of that I am
convinced and all I can say is that this
is a top priority for South Yorkshire
Police it will remain a top priority for
South Yorkshire police for as long as
I'm in this role and I can only say that
I hope to see that service has been
improved more of this crime being
prevented more victims being protected
and more of the perpetrators being
prosecuted and of that I give an
absolute pledging commitment going
forward and briefly do you think you did
anything wrong
of course I shared I take my share of
the responsibility there was systemic
failure and I only wish that I knew more
at the time if I knew then what I know
now then clearly more could have been
done I think I took appropriate actions
where that information was available I
do have regrets that perhaps I weren't
more aware of the issue at the time
where I could have perhaps influenced
services better but in the end I regret
my role in that systemic failure and
I've taken responsibility for that but
you feel ultimately you haven't failed
anyone I've just answered that question
I've taken my responsibility